hello and welcome to the 22nd PHP
tutorial where we left off we were
discussing md5 hashing but I did tell
you that they are crackable and there
are people with massive databases that
can crack your md5 hash in like a
millisecond so what can we do to combat
that and to come at that you can use a
kind of process called assaulting so
what's salting does is adds a little bit
of characters to the beginning or the
end of a password so what you can do is
let's do well we'll just erase this and
we're raise this so what you can do now
is let's say that password and then
salts will specify as that's our salt
now the next thing that you want to do
is the hashed version of password is
just this you know so hashed equals md5
pw okay the salted version equals md5
salt plus password
now we want to echo hash and then pull
out a couple breaks here and then we
want to echo out the salted version of
that hash
goodness I didn't even need those brakes
at the end whatever anyway so will
reupload that will come over refresh and
sure enough you know the this is typical
password this is the salted version of
that so when someone goes to run this
through it won't be as it won't relate
to the person's password it's going to
relate to the password and the salt and
so then what you can do is you're going
to start to get kind of fun with this
and you consult the heck out of this and
you can even do some string commands to
the password even the MU live version of
the password you could say like 20
characters in or like three characters
into the md5 hash of password you can
input the salt into there and so there's
a lot of different ways you can really
obfuscate the password and pretty much
make it almost as secure as something
like 128-bit encryption so anyways that
concludes the tutorial on hashing and
then subsequent salting as always thank
you for watching and until next time